[Musique]
une agence secrète faisant des choses partout dans
le monde que personne ne connaît
et c'est comme ça qu'ils aiment ça, ils n'en veulent pas
pour moi la grande maison du Royaume-Uni
[Musique]
étranger
35 ans de prison
peu de temps après ce barack  des
décennies plus tôt, obama revient à la télévision en tant que
commentateur puis bureau politique,
donc si vous êtes vraiment préoccupé
par la sécurité nationale de cette amérique, vous avez
quelqu'un pour être en colère contre barack obama
et pourtant, étrangement, personne ne l'est à la
place, ils sont furieux que julian
assange imprimait le  documents que d'
autres personnes ont volés
julian assange a longtemps été un
outil pervers d'amélioration du bien-être dans les
services de renseignement russes a écrit un
moralisateur professionnel ben sasse a également
servi au sénat américain il mérite de
passer le reste de sa vie en prison
avec lui
le reste de sa vie  à vie en prison,
je veux dire huit personnes n'ont jamais fait face à
ce genre de tempête,
pas même les gens ni pour le compte rendu, voudriez-
vous dire
qu'il est mort
et puis quand ils commencent à parler sur ce
micro ra  plus que
contesté
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un membre de l'armée dit
oh
[Musique]
allez
euh
[Applaudissements]
clare
[Musique]
est-ce que
vous les voyez porter leurs petits corps
et appeler à l'aide
[Musique]
zéro
le témoin clé
dans assange's  l'affaire admet avoir menti
dans l'acte d'accusation
êtes-vous prêt êtes-vous prêt un deux deux
l'affaire est à l'épreuve des balles
[Applaudissements]
exactement c'est tellement faux et c'est pourquoi
vous savez que je veux dire j'ai été vous savez
lire à ce sujet aussi et et j'ai presque
Je me sens bizarre quand je dis que
l'affaire s'effondre même si
c'est vrai que l'affaire s'effondre,
mais j'ai l'impression que parfois, quand vous dites
cette phrase, c'est presque comme si vous y étiez,
il y a une implication que l'affaire a
déjà été
montée ouais  vous savez donc c'est comme si cette
affaire ridicule et bidon qui n'aurait
même jamais dû s'approcher de ce point
en premier lieu
est devenue encore plus absurde
au point où vous ne pouviez pas présenter cela
comme un film
et nous sommes sur le point d'entrer dans
un major  ou témoin dans l'
affaire du ministère de la justice des États-Unis contre
Julian Assange a admis
avoir fabriqué des accusations clés dans l'
acte d'accusation et le fondateur de wikileaks
le témoin a une histoire documentée
avec la sociopathe sociopathe
croit la
sociopathie et a reçu plusieurs
prédictions d'abus sexuels
alors qu'il travaillait avec le département de
la justice
et le fbi et recevant une promesse d'
immunité contre les poursuites, je veux vraiment
lire à nouveau
le témoin qui a une histoire documentée
avec la sociopathie et a reçu plusieurs
condamnations pour abus sexuels sur mineurs
et pourquoi c'est leur témoin contre
julian assange
ils ont un mec  qui a des antécédents de
maladie mentale comme celle-ci et de
folie qu'ils ne lui donneront pas
avant s'il ment à propos de l'Allemagne
voyez-vous comment le gouvernement des États-
Unis prépare son dossier,
ils sont si honnêtes envers de si bonnes
personnes et il y a  plus que ça
aussi, il a un informateur du fbi
contre julian assange depuis 20  14
fumer comme ça,
il a commis des crimes sexuels, il va
aller en prison pour le reste de sa vie
et ils disent bon mentir à propos de ce gars
que nous essayons d'encadrer, nous allons vous laisser partir
et ils le font
et il a admis qu'il a gardé son  une
frénésie criminelle alors qu'il travaillait pour l'informateur du
ministère de la justice
en fait, il s'était porté volontaire sur une
base limitée pour collecter des fonds pour wikileaks en
2010, mais il a ensuite été découvert qu'il avait profité de
cette occasion pour détourner
ce type qu'ils sont assis pour témoigner
contre faire fils a été représenté a été
pris en train de voler de
wikileaks c'est leur témoin vedette l'
enquête de wikileaks sur le
détournement de fonds est ce qui a conduit le jeune homme
à retourner à nouveau les preuves de l'état
ne peut pas imaginer que ce gars
ne dirait pas la vérité sur quelque chose
ne peut pas imaginer
Je ne peux pas imaginer
que ça
va
[Applaudissements]
est
[Musique]
aucun de nous
euh
[Applaudissements]
serveurs
et a obtenu 35 ans de prison
peu de temps après que Barack Obama a
commué la peine de Manning, cela a permis à Manning
quitter la prison des décennies plus tôt revenir à la
télévision en tant que commentateur et
puis maintenant nous l'envoyons en prison
au lieu de se dénoncer
êtes-vous prêt pour cela
ce que l'affaire est à l'épreuve des balles
exactement c'est tellement faux et c'est pourquoi
vous savez que je veux dire  J'ai été vous savez
lire à ce sujet aussi et et je
me sens presque bizarre quand je dis que
l'affaire s'effondre même si
c'est vrai que l'affaire s'effondre
mais j'ai l'impression que parfois quand vous dites
cette phrase c'est presque comme toi '  re
il y a une implication que l'affaire a
jamais été montée en premier lieu
ouais vous savez donc c'est comme si cette
fausse affaire ridicule qui n'aurait
même jamais dû se rapprocher de ce point
en premier lieu est devenue encore
plus absurde
un témoin majeur dans  l'
affaire du département américain de la justice contre
julian assange a admis
avoir fabriqué des accusations clés à l'
acte d'accusation contre les wikileaks que
le témoin a documenté
et a reçu plusieurs condamnations  pour
abus sexuels sur mineurs
et
travaillant avec le ministère de la justice
et le fbi et recevant une promesse d'
immunité contre les poursuites, je veux vraiment
relire cela
le témoin qui a une histoire documentée
avec la sociopathie et a reçu plusieurs
condamnations pour abus sexuels sur mineurs
et pourquoi  c'est leur témoin clé
contre Julian Assange,
ils ont un gars qui a des antécédents de
maladie mentale comme celle-ci et
d'agressions sexuelles folles pour lesquelles ils vont maintenant
lui donner l'immunité car s'il ment à
propos de Julian Assange, pouvez-vous voir comment le
gouvernement des États-Unis  rassemble leur cas
, ils sont si honnêtes, ce sont de
si bonnes personnes oh ouais eh
bien et il y a plus que ça
aussi il était euh une performance du fbi euh
contre julian depuis 2014.
et
vous savez qu'il a commis de nombreuses
fraudes à la fois  il détournait de l'
argent de wikileaks eux-mêmes que
nous allons arriver à ce qui est ici
c'est vrai,
donc c'est exactement le genre de personnes avec
lesquelles le fbi travaille sur th  e régulier juste pour que
vous sachiez quand quelqu'un dit souvent
informateur du fbi c'est qui ces gens
sont ils ont des criminels avec des
esprits criminels et ils essaient d'encadrer
quelqu'un le fbi est
qu'ils essaient d'encadrer quelqu'un pour qu'ils
obtiennent de la fumée  comme celui-ci qui a commis
des crimes sexuels va aller en prison
pour le reste de sa vie et ils
lui disent hé mentir à propos de ce type que nous essayons
d'encadrer vous laissera partir
et ils le font
et il a admis qu'il avait gardé sa
frénésie criminelle  aller alors qu'il travaillait pour le
ministère de la justice et le fbi
wow
thordeson c'est le nom du gars
qu'il a été recruté par les autorités américaines les
induisant en erreur à
un menteur professionnel qui a été reconnu
coupable de détournement de fonds et de crimes sexuels
et a été un informateur du fbi
en fait il  s'était porté volontaire sur une
base limitée pour collecter des fonds pour wikileaks en
2010, mais a ensuite
profité de cette occasion pour détourner plus
de 50 000
de wikileaks
ce type qu'ils obtiennent pour témoigner
contre julian
a été condamné  ed s'est fait prendre en train de voler à
wikileaks c'est leur témoin vedette l'
enquête de wikileaks sur le
détournement de fonds est ce qui a conduit le jeune homme
à retourner à nouveau la preuve de l'état
ne peut pas imaginer que ce type
ne peut pas imaginer qu'il
ne peut pas
imaginer  Applaudissements]
il n'y a qu'une seule décision que
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour transmettre un message
à cette cour,
le lord juge en chef,
les juges, qu'il s'agit de
faire appel à la cour suprême
et nous avons un message pour ces juges,
nous avons un message pour le cps
et nous avons  un message pour les
procureurs fédéraux des états-unis
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
il n'y a qu'une seule décision pas d'extradition
us uk
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier
les médias internationaux ici aujourd'hui
qui couvrent le cas le plus important
de ce siècle
si ce n'est pour les 800 derniers  ans que
nous accordons ses droits ses
droits humains et légaux ont été niés
le droit d'avoir un procès équitable
le droit d'avoir un jury composé de ses pairs
et une présomption d'innocence h  tout a
été refusé ici à la haute cour et
des magistrats de Westminster,
nous voudrions remercier les médias britanniques,
veuillez lever la main
[Rires]
je pense que cela nous donne une réponse d'
accord,
les médias britanniques
sont peut-être les prochains et ils se recroquevillent dans leurs
bureaux,
ils  transporter chez eux en buvant du
chianti et du café
et nous leur demandons de couvrir cette affaire
aujourd'hui
pour couvrir la réalité de la fin d'une
presse libre
où nous nous inclinons devant les États-Unis et extradons l'un
des plus grands journalistes et
éditeurs du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
s'il vous plaît faites circuler ce média
s'il vous plaît communiquez avec vos amis
famille et groupes sociaux
et
découvrez par vous-même la vérité sur
julian assange
et la criminalité
qui couvre un homme qui a
dénoncé la criminalité de guerre non seulement
en afghanistan et en irak mais aujourd'hui
en syrie en palestine au yémen ils
ravagent les populations civiles
ils tuent et détruisent des civils
et ils pensent au nom de la liberté
et de la démocratie  cy eh bien nous le faisons au
nom de la liberté d'expression
chilien libre assange
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
plus
[Musique]
vraiment important afghanistan
[Applaudissements]
ma voiture se maquille
[Musique]
c'est
je vais répondre à ça  une
[Musique]
euh
tu sais
[Musique]
ils ne regardent pas
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[La musique]
est
étrangère
tout le monde
oh
mon dieu
[Applaudissements]
et c'est  prendre deux ans
je pense que nous devrions
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] au
revoir
[Musique]
ça va
oui
mec
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
[Musique]
sortez-le
euh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
oui
euh d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
euh
personne n'est une
arme qui est l'hélicoptère apache
jamais
documenté
par les gens
qui devraient faire leur travail
donc le montant de la garantie
mais personne
n'a publié de photos
de  l'arme du crime qui était l'
hélicoptère apache
je me demande pourquoi
qu'en est-il des
armes et des investisseurs
qu'en est-il du
la citation de julian assange
toutes les guerres ont été créées par des mensonges je
répéterai que
toutes les guerres ont été créées par des mensonges
donc la preuve pour ceux qui sont
intéressés à faire leur travail
est la preuve collatérale de la vidéo du meurtre
toujours pas de photos du commandant
et de l'équipage de l'apache  équipage d'hélicoptère
qui a assassiné des innocents et des
enfants,
je me demande pourquoi
nous avons un dilemme ici,
la livraison
est un journaliste, quelqu'un qui fait des recherches
et révèle la vérité ou est-ce quelqu'un
qui ne copie pas et ne colle pas
par récit contrôlé, il y a un
dilemme dans le  mot journaliste
où est la preuve de l'
équipage de l'hélicoptère apache
qui sait
qui a la
preuve la vidéo du meurtre collatéral
où est-elle
elle aurait dû être saisie comme
preuve
où sont les photographies
donc le 11 avril
si cela continue
ce sera trois ans  depuis julian
assange
oui c'est le mot correct parce que les
gens n'ont pas demandé que cela se produise donc
donc c'est un enlèvement il a été
kidnappé
donc si vous  restez justice
montrez-moi la preuve de toute justice
montrez-moi juste parce que vous avez une
personne soudée qui détient les compétences qui
est soudée en transition
cela ne signifie pas la justice
si vous dites que c'est un appel de la
justice montrez-moi la preuve  de la justice
ne
vous a jamais montré la justice
si vous allez utiliser la
justice,
vous devez avoir une preuve réelle
de ce qui se passe,
donc les nids d'abeilles de Frankie sont l'équipage de la
preuve
ouais et toujours personne n'est accusé
toujours pas de photos de l'
hélicoptère apache qui sur les armes du crime
toujours pas de photos du commandant de
l'équipage de l'hélicoptère apache
qui a rendu ce meurtre possible
en remontant à la citation de julian assange toutes les
guerres ont été créées par des mensonges
il y a un dilemme dans le mot
journaliste
c'est un journaliste quelqu'un qui révèle
la vérité et fait la recherche  ou est-ce qu'un
journaliste quelqu'un qui fait du copier-
coller
dans un
récit contrôlé,
quelqu'un a une réponse à cela,
donc vous avez la preuve que l'hélicoptère apache
t  la vidéo sur le meurtre collatéral,
nous avons maintenant deux ans et demi
et vous dites justice,
montrez-moi la preuve de l'endroit où la justice est
[Musique]
étrange,
alors devrions-nous utiliser le mot justice
où la liberté d'un homme lui
a été retirée
alors  quelqu'un peut-il copier et coller et être
journaliste cela signifie-t-il que si vous avez un appareil photo
et que vous copiez et
collez cela fait-il de vous un journaliste ou est-ce un
journaliste quelqu'un qui se fait
éventuellement jouer par un groupe d'hélicoptères
montre la preuve documentaire de la
vidéo classique
et met les criminels en prison julius les
scientifiques vous ont dit que
toutes les guerres ont été créées par des mensonges combien de
preuves avez-vous besoin de deux ans et demi
dans ce
total
maintenant quand vous dites que je suis journaliste voulez-vous
dire que je suis une copie du marchand de voitures de course
et mon récit est contrôlé ou
punissez-vous la vérité
je n'ai trouvé aucune preuve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
être contrôlé par le récit qui est
malheureux mais la vie d'un homme
est en prison en ce moment pendant 23 heures par
jour  parce que personne
ne publie la vérité
où est
[Musique]
alors maintenant la signification d'un journaliste à
moins que vous ne prouviez le contraire est une copie
du récit à rythme contrôlé,
cela ne signifie pas
que vous avez publié la vérité
désolé mais cela pourrait fonctionner si vous êtes  un
média en continu raté, vous ne m'aimez peut-être pas
, je veux dire que vous n'êtes pas assis dans une
cellule de prison pendant 23 heures par jour lorsque vous rentrez chez
vous, vous pouvez mettre vos pieds en l'air,
essayez de marquer la dimension de la cellule sur le
sol en y restant pendant 23 heures par  jour
juste un jour
vous avez tous un bon équipement
pour moi c'est le terrain de badminton du club de
tennis mais certainement
jamais
devant la justice
ils vont essayer d'entrer dans mon
bien sûr
ils ont les preuves
des vidéos de meurtre virtuel mais
non  photos pas de documentation de l'
hélicoptère apache qui est l'arme du crime
oui pas de photos des personnes qui ont
commis le meurtre
le commandant et l'équipage
là-bas
essayaient de l'obtenir
beaucoup beaucoup
vous êtes censé fournir aux
gens la vérité
quand  re est-ce
où est-ce
assange
depuis toujours
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
prétendre
revenir c'est un court de tennis c'est un
terrain de badminton mais ce n'est certainement pas un lieu de
justice
qu'espérez-vous aujourd'hui car vous
espérez aller sur un autre terrain et en avoir
six  des mois de plus à traîner avec cette
façade ridicule qu'espérez-vous
bien
toujours toutes les guerres ont été drainées par la
lumière
se lever le matin et dire
ce mantra toutes les guerres créent ma vie
c'est ce que julian hassan vient de dire
alors ne me dis pas toi  es un journaliste
tu pourrais être bon tu pourrais nous
pourrions rire ensemble la question est
qu'il s'agit de la vie d'un homme mais
comment se fait-il que nous ayons 150 prisons en
angleterre
et en irlande toutes les réponses
donc si vous dites justice comment se fait-
il  j'ai
150 cadeaux avec un nouveau en construction
à wellington qu'est-ce que c'est
oh nous continuons juste à
nous entendre gardez la tête
bien baissée pendant combien de temps [ __ ] oui j'ai juré
parce que je crois que julian assange
mérite un bien meilleur traitement t  han il
obtient
maintenant la question est julian pour mettre le
niveau des journalistes
très
haut
donc
je n'ai rien contre aucun de vous
individuellement la question est si vous
dites la presse
si vous êtes ici pour soutenir la justice s'il vous plaît
montrez-moi la preuve
où est-il comment se fait-il
que l'équipage de l'hélicoptère apache l'
hélicoptère n'ait pas été mis
en fourrière comme preuve
je ne sais vraiment pas vous savez la
question maintenant est que
les enfants vont à l'école avec des
masques sur vous dites que cela n'a rien à
voir avec cela tout est lié
tout  documentation à ce sujet,
alors
peut-être que vous irez devant un autre tribunal aujourd'hui
, puis peut-être qu'ils traîneront pendant
encore six mois
et gagneront un peu plus d'argent, mais la
question maintenant est de savoir si l'un d'entre vous pense
qu'il y a une justice dans ce
bâtiment
avez-vous  n'avez aucune preuve de justice
à tout moment de ce bâtiment,
dites simplement Gary
et nous disons que nous ne nous soucions pas de vous
parce que nous avons ce système qui
s'appelle allez-y
gardez la tête bien baissée pendant combien de temps
[Musique  ]
ce pays l'angleterre a été construit sur
la même chose
maintenant je ne suis pas contre
ce que c'est la question est de
dire
aux enfants que
vous feriez mieux de mentir
parce que regardez ce qui est arrivé à julian
assange ou traitons-nous de ce qui doit
être traité  c'est une façade c'est une
imposture
nous avons 150 prisons chaque prison aura
peut-être 500 détenus où est la
justice le mot journalistes signifie-t-il
copier-coller
gardez la tête baissée
dans le récit c'est la vie d'un homme
[Musique]
Est-ce que c'est bon de laisser ça aux enfants
et aux petits-enfants ou devons-nous faire
face à ce qui doit être fait
Je ne parle pas d'attaquer qui que ce soit
Je ne parle pas de violence Je
parle de si cela dit justice
là-haut
mais où est l'évolution
de la scène
vers l'économie merci
[Applaudissements]
eh bien la question est maintenant
si nous parlons de justice
et que vous soudez la balance au milieu
alors vous n'avez pas un
donc la question est deux et un
six mois le 11 avril 3  Ces dernières années, les
étudiants sont juste kidnappés,
c'est un homme bon
oh
[Applaudissements]
je pensais que tu t'adressais à moi
[Applaudissements] c'est
vrai
[Musique]
nous devons suivre cette voie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réponds au problème
oh
[  Musique]
peut-être qu'elle est sous couverture, elle
ne veut vraiment pas être filmée
je sais ce que tu as raison
oh
allez
oh d'
accord
[Musique]
merci
ce n'est pas un vrai tribunal tu sais que
le juge
juge burnett
est  le meilleur ami de l'un des pires ennemis de julian le
juge burnett est un ami d'alan duncan
qui a orchestré la saisie de julian de
l'ambassade équatorienne
vrai
ouais ce n'est pas un vrai procès dis au
monde
qu'ils sachent que nous avons pensé et menti aussi
mais c'est le meilleur homme
c'est à quel point c'est corrompu
dites au monde que les britanniques ordinaires
devraient avoir honte ce n'est pas un
appel kangourou de la justice britannique
merci
[Musique
] c'est un procès corrompu ce n'est pas vraiment
une livraison d'essai
appropriée  euh
celui-là
ouais ouais si tu veux venir
euh ouais personne d'autre ne le veut au micro
ouais si tu pouvais venir un peu ouais
à ce rapport kangourou pour le
haut-commissaire australien
ouais l'
ignorant habilement
c'est vrai les explosifs ont planté
nous aimons  la nourriture
étrangère
oh
[Musique]
est-
ce que vous êtes sur vous êtes sur la
bonne voie sommes-nous prêts
[Rires]
mesdames et messieurs
annonce officielle c'est pour attirer l'attention de tout le monde
mesdames et messieurs puis
-je avoir votre attention s'il vous plaît
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui
habillé  en tant que faucheuse
pour annoncer officiellement
que la justice britannique est morte
cette affaire n'est pas compliquée
c'est vraiment très simple
comme la faucheuse
pour annoncer officiellement
que la justice britannique est morte l'
affaire n'est pas compliquée
c'est vraiment très simple
julian assange est un journaliste
qui a monté wikilea  ks
pour exposer les mauvaises choses faites
par de mauvaises personnes à travers le monde,
c'est bien qu'elles soient exposées
car cela signifie que les bonnes personnes
comme nous ont
une chance d'arrêter ces mauvaises
personnes
wikileaks et tout ce que Julian a fait
est
parfaitement légal
mais cela a fait  lui des ennemis très puissants
en particulier le gouvernement des états-unis
donc ils ont soudoyé
oui le gouvernement des états-unis a soudoyé
une personne appelée thordeson pour qu'il mente
en disant que julian l'a fait pirater
et le piratage est illégal
cependant
thordeson a maintenant admis qu'il a menti
et julian l'a fait absolument  rien d'
illégal ou de mal,
donc il n'y a maintenant absolument aucun cas
d'extradition de julian en
outre, la raison pour laquelle thordesen a
menti contre julian
était parce que les états-unis ont dit
qu'ils lui accorderaient l'immunité contre les
poursuites pour ses propres crimes,
ceux-ci incluent des relations sexuelles avec 15 garçons mineurs
dont l'un a commis  suicide, je me suis empressé
d'ajouter des
pensées et j'ai également commis
une fraude financière et un détournement
de fonds à grande échelle dans  résumé
cette affaire n'est pas compliquée
penséeerson est le seul témoin contre
julian
et maintenant il a admis qu'il a été soudoyé par
le gouvernement des états-unis pour mentir
contre julian
l'affaire contre julian est absolument
sans fondement
c'est aussi simple que ça
donc c'est une imposture absolument dégoûtante de
so-  appelé la justice qui se
passe dans ce sordide petit
tribunal kangourou derrière moi la
justice britannique ne défendra
absolument rien
dans le monde si ce tribunal ne libère pas
immédiatement
Julian Assange
[Applaudissements]
libère
le commissaire qui n'est qu'à un saut et à
un saut de la haute
condition australienne sur la route tout au long de mon droit
de venir ici et de voir quels actes d'
injustice sont perpétrés contre le
citoyen australien qu'il n'a pas fait a
levé le doigt
pour aider
george brandes devrait avoir honte de
lui-même c'est un tribunal kangourou
sauter et sauter ici ex-procureur
général de l'australie et voir ce qui a
b  een perpétré sur un
citoyen australien sans agression maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je pense que la raison pour laquelle ce n'est pas
parce qu'ils ont vraiment peur de l'
histoire
l'histoire est que nous avons été témoins que les États-Unis ont
introduit très tard dans la deuxième journée
des semaines avant le week-end,
j'ai attendu jusqu'à deux semaines avant
euh ouais mesdames et messieurs juste pour ajouter
à ces points plus tôt je veux dire regardez l'
essentiel est que je suis venu ici en tant que
faucheuse juste pour dire que la justice britannique
est morte mais juste pour y aller  juste pour vous montrer à
quel point
tout ce procès est complètement faible, dépravé et corrompu,
euh comme je l'ai dit,
thordeson vit juste google pense et vis,
tu entreras au cœur de cette histoire,
leurs principaux témoins ont menti euh,
il y a huit raisons pour lesquelles ce n'est pas
un bon  procès
pendant des années alors que julian était à l'
ambassade équatorienne euh les américains
espionnaient et enregistraient toutes ses rencontres légalement
privilégiées euh avec ses avocats
pendant environ trois ou quatre ans euh sur cette
base l'affaire pourrait être rejetée si
cela  était un bon procès
ce n'est pas un bon procès c'est
mon point principal
euh ils ont finalement quand julian a été
kidnappé est probablement une meilleure
expression mais ils l'appellent arrêté et
saisi à l'ambassade équatorienne le
gouvernement des états-unis a volé
neuf ans de légal de julian
documentation, il a perdu neuf ans
de toute sa documentation juridique,
ils ont été expédiés aux États-Unis euh
les personnes qui poursuivent et en
fait les amarrages juridiques de Julian ont été
volés, c'est donc une autre raison pour laquelle
ce procès devrait être euh rejeté
euh les États-Unis ont également
comploté pour  tue julian
euh tu sais que nous ne pouvons pas le royaume-uni le
gouvernement britannique ne devrait pas exciter euh
julian dans un pays où ils ont
déjà comploté pour le tuer
aussi le juge juge burnett
actuellement là-bas sur le point de rendre un verdict
qu'il considérera  comme justice, mais sera sans aucun
doute une sorte de piège qui
nous fera perdre encore un an
avant qu'ils euh
avant même que nous n'arrivions à une sorte de
jouer au niveau pour un terrain où nous pourrions
aller devant un tribunal qui nous rendra
justice mais mon point est que burnett est
un ami de euh alan duncan le euh le
politicien qui a orchestré la
saisie de julian de l'ambassade équatorienne donc
il n'est pas il ne devrait pas juger  dans
ce procès, ce procès est complètement corrompu
sortez-vous de la tête que c'est un
vrai procès ce n'est pas un vrai procès
euh
l'autre chose est évidemment
politique je pense que tout le monde ici serait d'
accord que c'est politique mais en vertu de la loi de 2003 sur les
expositions, vous pouvez  ne pas extrader pour
des procès politiques, donc pour ce motif, cette
affaire devrait être rejetée
euh
aussi il a été emprisonné à l'
isolement à belmont à environ huit miles de
là sans accès à ses avocats
je suppose qu'il n'est même pas ici aujourd'hui
c'est une imposture complète de la justice  se passe
devant ce tribunal derrière nous
euh
et il y a donc huit raisons pour
lesquelles ce procès devrait être
rejeté mais je vais juste vous laisser avec
une pensée une citation
fr  om nils
melter nils melzer est le répertoire des nations unies euh
sur la torture
et euh il en a fait quelques-uns il a fait une
très bonne citation qui euh il a fait deux
citations en fait je vais vous donner la
première qu'il dit et c'est un homme de
respect international
absolument intègre et très euh
très crédible à travers le monde et niels
melzer dit que julian assange est
lentement torturé à mort par les gouvernements
pour avoir dénoncé leurs mensonges
crimes et corruption
donc c'est une citation vraiment accablante de
nils melzer sur euh ce qui se passe
et la dernière citation  je vais vous laisser
avec
est euh nils parle de la
justice britannique et nils miles un
rapporteur spécial des nations unies sur la
torture dit que les britanniques et je cite que
la justice britannique
a livré une parodie complète d'un
procès
où l'accusé a  n'a pas eu le droit
de préparer sa défense
là où il n'a pas eu accès à ses propres
avocats
là où nous avons le juge les juges du tribunal
refusant
d'examiner les objections o  f leurs propres
conflits d'intérêts comme burnett a
comme notre baignoire aussi
et
nils poursuit en disant que même au
royaume-uni julian assange n'obtiendra pas un
procès d'extradition équitable
fin de citation
donc voilà un homme d'
estime internationale
déchirant  à part ce soi-disant
système judiciaire dans ce pays ce n'est pas un
vrai procès s'il vous plait dites au monde ce qui
se passe nous avons besoin d'un tribunal de l'opinion publique
pour
envoyer cette affaire envoyer cette affaire pour arrêter cette affaire par
le niveau politique et public c'est
pas un vrai procès ne vous y trompez pas
julian n'obtiendra pas justice aujourd'hui
quel que soit le verdict de ce
tribunal kangourou derrière moi sera une
forme d'exercice de perte de temps trompeur
parce qu'ils ne voudront pas aller au tribunal
avec tous ces huit points contre eux
merci  vous êtes très
libre julian assange
voyage gratuit
[Applaudissements]
balle gratuite libre
quelqu'un d'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
ça ressemble à un capot étant
vous wow toujours um
parler abo  ut l'adn qu'ils essaient de
supposer que ce n'est pas si important
ouais ouais ouais
je sais que c'est horrible
tout à fait horrible
car tu as raison euh ce sera une grande
démonstration qui amènera en
juillet sur le site Web de dea
je ne me souviens plus ce que c'est
1000.
[Musique]
Heureusement que j'en ai fini avec ça
oh
hey
euh
[Musique] d'
accord
[Musique]
merci
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trois
[Musique]
recherche
oh
france
[Applaudissements]
oh
moi
trois
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
les bonnes personnes ici aujourd'hui
sont venues élever la voix
et expriment leur indignation face
au processus judiciaire qui accorde à assange
plus de 10 ans
sept ans à l'ambassade équatorienne
le bâtiment le plus surveillé au
monde des
dizaines de millions de l'argent de nos contribuables
utilisé pour surveiller un journaliste australien
et asile équatorien
après des milliards de dollars de  l'argent du FMI
à Lénine corrompu
moreno en équateur,
il a accepté de remettre julian aux autorités britanniques
sur la promesse
d'une demande d'extradition américaine
qui n'était pas encore apparue
après trois ans plus de mille jours
d'isolement et de torture à hnp belmont
julian est sur le fil un homme qui a été
isolé au point
de se détériorer mentalement et physiquement,
sa fiancée nous dit
que julian assange
ne sera jamais extradé vers les états-unis d'un pays
où il risque
175 ans de condamnation à mort,
les papiers qui pourraient bientôt arriver sur
le bureau de la jolie patel
si cette haute cour  décider de nier
refuser l'appel de julian assange
nous demandons non seulement aux
médias internationaux et aux médias britanniques de défendre le
journalisme dans une presse libre
et nous exigeons de ces dieux
qu'il n'y ait qu'une décision
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
nous disons
us
uk
us uk
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
nous supposons
que nous
avons décidé que la demande d'extradition des États-Unis
est parfaitement raisonnable
et que l'assurance des
États-Unis que Junior Assad vous verrez recevoir fai  r traitement
non seulement dans le tribunal de Virginie mais dans
le système pénitentiaire américain
un mensonge
un mensonge éhonté par les autorités américaines
et lâchement répété par le cps
et bizarrement accepté par ce tribunal
ici aujourd'hui
nous exigeons que l'union lui ait accordé sa liberté ses
droits humains et légaux
nous exigeons que le public britannique
s'oppose à cette indignation
à cette extradition injustifiée l'
enlèvement illégal et l'interprétation fade
de julian assange aux états-unis est une
condamnation à mort ils savaient qu'il y a 10 ans
ils savent qu'aujourd'hui
écoutez gratuitement assange
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît prenez quelques  temps
sur vos contacts de médias sociaux
sur vos
contacts de médias internationaux euh
et en effet
les chacals lâches des médias
britanniques s'il vous plaît prenez note de ce qu'ils font à Julian Assange aujourd'hui
ils vous feront
demain
votre liberté votre liberté d'expression et en effet
votre vie sera en danger
et ils utilisent l'examen junior assange comme
exemple de ce qui est arrivé aux journalistes
pour publier la vérité sur
ce qui arrive à wikileaks un pub en
ligne légitime  plate-forme de pêche qui est
décrite comme une
agence de renseignement hostile par mike pompeo l'ancien
procureur général des états-unis
et aujourd'hui joe biden
continue sa politique
et refuse à julian assange ses
droits légaux et humains
il n'y a qu'une seule décision
[Applaudissements]
Royaume-Uni
je pense que le jugement est en train d'être lu
en ce moment
maintenant euh
christopher branson
et morris sont dans le tribunal
et quand ils sortiront du tribunal euh
j'espère qu'ils nous donneront quelques
conseils de sagesse de la procédure d'
aujourd'hui merci
[Musique]
une chose
ils ont besoin d'une permission
euh
[Musique]
apparemment
est
[Musique]
oh
euh d'
accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] la
justice prend du temps tu sais
[Musique]
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a mieux  une là-bas
justin
quand elle est
la levrette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
c'est
oui
j'ai dit
c'est
[Musique]
euh
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire attention car nous
sommes coincés dans la piste des bérets depuis plus d'un
an  quoi que ce soit  Je suis du verdict,
ce sera probablement une forme de piège,
alors soyons prudents,
cela signifiera une autre année en isolement,
probablement la baie britannique de Guantanamo ouais
toujours incarcéré
et s'ils l'attrapent, ils seront après vous
ensuite, ils ne le feront pas  être après ces deux
personnes,
ils seront là-haut
[Musique]
nous avons un système judiciaire
c'est écrit la justice britannique a
été rendue dans ce bâtiment si vous
croyez que vous êtes une tasse absolue beaucoup
c'est une imposture ce qui se passe là-dedans et
il y aura probablement un piège jailli aujourd'hui
comme nous l'avons eu du brésil nous sommes coincés
dans un piège à bérets depuis plus d'un an à nous disputer
pour savoir si julian est suicidaire
ou si oui ou non la juliette le
système pénitentiaire américain est mauvais nous
savons tous julian  suicidaire toute
personne sensée serait suicidaire il
traverse l'enfer nous le laissons
nous de bonnes personnes ici je pense que c'est tellement
mal et nous sommes ici pour protester
merci
ils le gardent en isolement jusqu'à sa
mort ouais pourquoi a-t-il besoin  être en
solitaire  ary pourquoi ne peut-il pas être en liberté sous caution comme
pinochet était pinochet était exactement dans la
même position que julian il a échoué dans
une maison de luxe pourquoi julian
n'échoue-t-il pas une disgrâce ils le torturent
c'est une imposture absolue de justice
trois ans vous  sachez que vous avez toujours été
en isolement en
train de mourir lentement une autre année maintenant pour faire appel
c'est absolument honteux brewton est une
honte mondiale c'est tellement
honteux ce que nous faisons et les
gens ordinaires devraient simplement se lever et être
comptés et dire non nous ne voulons pas ça  en
notre nom, c'est tellement profondément faux
[Musique]
merci,
continuez
[Musique]
tout le monde veut faire
[Applaudissements]
euh
quelque chose de grand public ouais pourquoi même ils n'avaient presque rien à propos de la marche n'ont-ils
rien trouvé
mais ils le font
[Musique]
mais ils parlent comme
et al jazeera sont les seuls endroits
[Musique]
où est le haut-commissaire australien
aujourd'hui, il devrait être ici pour soutenir son
citoyen mais vous ne le voyez jamais
parce que l'Australie est dans le con  oui
il porte des boutons de manchette cia apparemment
bien je dis apparemment c'est bien
documenté
quel
dommage  Musique]
[Musique]
je sais que je sais
et puis les gens pourraient entrer et sortir
et nous ne serions pas sur leur chemin ils sont
juste difficiles ce gars a juste
été difficile il ne prendrait même pas un
dépliant mais le ferait  Je n'écoute même pas
un autre point
ouais pouvons-nous avoir le chien
parce que c'est juste qu'il y a tellement de
gens que
vous connaissez
c'est
si ce sont vos haut-parleurs pourrions-nous
les reculer un peu je veux dire je ne
veux pas juste
[Musique]
désolé
salut gloria je ne suis qu'humain je suis désolé comment
tu vas tu vas bien
tu vas  en marche sur facebook
euh
[Musique]
[Rires]
un héros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] d'
accord
[Musique]
merci à tous d'être venus  jour
ce qui s'est passé devant le tribunal au lieu de
parler
commencer contre ella s'il vous plaît
ce qui s'est passé devant le tribunal aujourd'hui est
précisément ce que nous voulions qu'il se produise
la haute cour a certifié
que nous avions soulevé
un point de droit d'
importance publique générale
et que la cour suprême a bon
motifs
pour entendre cet appel,
la situation est maintenant que la
Cour suprême doit décider si elle entendra
l'appel,
mais ne vous y trompez pas, nous avons gagné aujourd'hui devant le
tribunal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais n'oublions pas que chaque fois que nous
gagnons
aussi longtemps que cela  l'affaire n'est pas abandonnée
tant que julian n'est pas libéré
julian continue de souffrir
depuis près de trois ans il est à
la prison de belmar et il souffre
profondément
jour après jour semaine après semaine année après
année
julian doit être libéré
et nous espérons
que cela  va bientôt se terminer
mais nous sommes loin d'obtenir justice dans
cette affaire car julian est
incarcéré depuis si longtemps et il n'aurait
pas dû passer un seul jour en prison
s'il y avait eu justice l'o  les officiels
qui ont comploté
qui ont comploté pour assassiner julian
seraient dans la salle d'audience en ce moment
s'il y avait justice les crimes que
julian a révélés crimes de guerre le meurtre de
civils innocents ne seraient pas contestés
notre combat continue et nous le combattrons
jusqu'à ce que julian soit libre merci
[Musique]
mais
le point qui est soulevé ici dans
ce tribunal était l'absurdité
qu'après que le tribunal de première instance ait pris
une décision,
les américains ont été autorisés à
apporter les soi-disant assurances qu'ils
traiteraient Julian équitablement si et  quand il
était en fait aux États-Unis,
tout le monde qui a examiné ces
soi-disant assurances les
a condamnées et jugées comme
ne valant pas le papier sur lequel elles sont
écrites. Le
gouvernement américain a déjà fait de telles
assurances et ils ont rompu
ces assurances.
impliquent dans ces assurances
la clause qu'ils peuvent changer d'
avis à tout moment
donc ça ne vaut rien mais comme le
dit stella le combat wi  Je continuerai
et cela ne se terminera pas tant que Julian ne sera pas
libéré de la prison de Belmont et jusqu'à
ce que le gouvernement américain abandonne cette affaire qui
est une attaque flagrante et grave contre la
liberté de la presse dans le monde,
mais aujourd'hui, c'était une victoire partielle,
une victoire partielle,
mais Asella dit que
la punition continue
c'est une punition par procédure une grave
violation des droits de l'homme la torture est en
cours dans la prison de belmont il est
là depuis plus de 1 000 jours ce
qui se passe ici dans ce pays
aujourd'hui c'est l'élément le plus récent de la journée
merci d'
accord
donc des journalistes sans  frontières je
voudrais juste ajouter encore une fois nous nous félicitons de
cette décision c'est une étape positive
ce n'est pas encore assez loin mais c'est un pas
dans la bonne direction
cette affaire est historique elle créera
énormément de précédents elle aura des
implications pour le journalisme et la
liberté de la presse  au Royaume-Uni aux États-Unis et à l'
étranger pendant de nombreuses années à venir,
il mérite d'être examiné par le plus haut tribunal
de ce pays et nous espérons donc vivement
que le  la cour suprême acceptera cet
appel
comme d'autres l'ont également dit la
situation dans laquelle julian assange lui-même se
trouve est très urgente nous avons de sérieuses
inquiétudes quant à son bien-être à la
prison de belmarsh les problèmes de santé mentale de longue date
sont bien documentés nous
avons des inquiétudes quant à son  santé physique
aussi, surtout sachant ce que nous savons
maintenant sur le mini-accident vasculaire cérébral qu'il a
subi en octobre et sur les
rapports d'infections de convoitise en augmentation dans
la prison à ce moment-là, il n'est pas en
sécurité tant qu'il est là, il devrait être
immédiatement libéré  pendant que ce processus
est en cours, donc de la part de reporters sans
frontières, nous continuerons à faire campagne euh
pour libérer assange, nous appelons à
nouveau l'administration biden à abandonner les charges
pour clore cette affaire une fois pour toutes, ce
processus judiciaire n'a pas à continuer,
il est dans le  pouvoir de ceux du
gouvernement américain de mettre un terme à cela à tout
moment, ils peuvent le faire et nous continuerons
d'être ici et de surveiller toute autre
procédure judiciaire  dings dans ce cas
trois deux
trois trois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois deux
trois trois deux
[Musique]
tu dois le rebrancher comme ça
[Applaudissements]
oh
applications
[Applaudissements]
presque trois ans
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh ils rentrent à la maison non je suis là
qui est increasable et silencieux
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sont pas
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
euh
merci
bien
euh
[Applaudissements]
commencer à prendre
[Applaudissements] d'
accord
oh
[Applaudissements]
euh
[Musique]
merci
étrangère
[Musique]
oh
euh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien, comme je l'ai dit plus tôt, je veux dire que ce n'est
qu'une victoire partielle mais très
importante sur un point très important,
mais je pense que euh
euh
tu sais bien sûr que
ce dont nous avons besoin pour cette affaire sera
abandonné  tout à fait c'est c'est c'est
la seule
vraie victoire pour pour pour le journalisme mais
pour julian c'est bien sûr un pro
incarcération tant attendue il est déjà depuis plus
de mille jours dans la prison de belmont
c'est inaccessible maintenant nous avons il doit
être là au moins
quelques mois de plus cela pourrait prendre des mois
à la cour suprême pour
décider d'entendre l'affaire ou non mais euh
comme  je dis que c'est une partie d'une
victoire partielle mais c'est loin d'être fini
avez-vous des nouvelles sur cette aide euh
[Musique]
vous pouvez juste imaginer quel genre de
situation c'est d'être tout ce temps en
prison
je veux dire vous vous tous  entendu les nouvelles
de son euh
euh
accident vasculaire cérébral mineur et
sa santé décline c'est euh
c'est tout ce que je peux dire euh
combien de temps cela prendra bien je veux dire il
y a je pense 14 jours pour que l'
avocat Julius soumette des documents à la
cour suprême alors nous  Je n'ai aucune idée du
temps que prendra la Cour suprême pour
décider ou prendre une décision, cela pourrait
prendre des semaines pourrait prendre des mois, mais
c'est sur un point un point très important
euh quel point nous avons toujours
vous
savez euh protester vigoureusement contre le  fait
qu'après que les États-Unis aient perdu devant le
tribunal inférieur, ils ont été autorisés à
soumettre ces soi-disant assurances absurdes,
ce que je veux dire
du point de vue du général,
c'est juste absurde, c'est absurde
que vous soyez autorisé à
tenter de modifier votre  cas dans un
processus d'appel quelque chose que je veux dire
qu'ils ont eu toutes les occasions de présenter
cela devant le tribunal méditerranéen, ils
ne l'ont pas fait
seulement après avoir perdu, ils sont venus avec
ces soi-disant assurances
assurance qu'amnesty international une autre
organisation a trouvé qu'elle était absolument
insuffisante et  et cela ne vaut rien
, pensez-vous qu'il y a des progrès grâce à
la contribution des politiciens australiens
qui se sont maintenant bien exprimés,
je veux dire de plus en plus de
politiciens s'expriment et il est très
important qu'ils se lèvent et nous avons des
hommes d'État qui s'expriment euh
dans  en in et donc de plus en plus de
voix rentrent dans le mix ça se
précise de plus en plus
euh la gravité de cette affaire
c'est quand même été  o atteindre le niveau
des politiciens qui sont au pouvoir
euh et
nous espérons que cela viendra
maintenant qu'ils verront que c'est juste
quelque chose qu'ils ne peuvent pas ignorer vous
ne pouvez pas détourner le regard
vous devez aborder ce problème c'est d'une
telle importance merci  vous
pouvez nous demander votre réaction à la
saison aujourd'hui c'était une bonne journée
euh qui s'est déroulée aussi bien que nous pouvions vous
savoir peut-être attendez-vous à ce que nous soyons
souvent renversés euh souvent très injustement
devant les tribunaux mais
que c'était bien que cela ait accepté que
c'est un  point d'intérêt public général
que les
États ne devraient pas être en mesure de simplement
soumettre de nouvelles assurances dans une
note diplomatique après avoir perdu
et c'est un point important plus qu'un
simple point de procédure car
ces assurances n'ont été soumises qu'au
stade des appels  jamais testé,
il n'y a jamais eu d'argument devant le tribunal quant
à la validité
et à la fiabilité de ces assurances et
en fait,
vous savez qu'elles ne sont absolument
pas fiables, les États-Unis ont émis une
assurance  ces avant dans des cas similaires
qu'ils ont procédé euh pour choisir notamment
le cas d'abu hamza par exemple
un monsieur
sans mains
qui n'est pas capable de se raser ou de se couper les
ongles ou de prendre soin de lui et toutes
les assurances quant à la façon dont il  aurait été
traité aurait été rompu,
c'est donc un point important, la
Cour suprême va maintenant décider de se saisir de
l'affaire et nous nous attendons à ce qu'une Cour suprême
se saisisse de l'affaire et nous espérons gagner
l'affaire merci
[Applaudissements]
bon travail
[  Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
euh j'espère que cela se terminera bientôt
que la cour suprême entendra
cette affaire, espérons qu'elle doit encore
décider et si elle le fait, elle mettra
enfin fin à cela pour que julian puisse être
libre et pour que cela  l'extradition peut
prendre fin une fois pour toutes
il souffre chaque jour il souffre
en prison
il ne purge aucun crime aucune peine
pour aucun crime il est juste là parce que
les états-unis prennent cette
persécution politique scandaleuse contre le
éditeur parce que
[Applaudissements]